[Music]
but somebody lied
and we need to know who an explosive
revelation that two quebec ministers
were aware of the crisis at the heron
long-term care facility before they said
they knew
en
el
an email obtained by radio canada shows
that the minister responsible for
seniors marguerite blay and the health
minister in 2020 danielle mccann were
advised of troubling staff shortages at
the chsld heron on march 29th and 30th
respectively contradicting what they
told the coroner that they only learned
about the chaotic situation when they
read it in the newspaper that article
was published april 10 2020. what do we
have in this email they say
the sears so mrs mcveigh
responsible of the issues she will take
charge of the situation in aaron so of
course mrs blair mrs mccann myself
we were comfortable to hear
that
the sous was taking charge of this
situation the west island long-term care
center was ravaged by covet 19. staff
quit on mass leaving residents who were
dehydrated soiled and ridden with covet
19 to their own devices about 100
seniors died in dire circumstances when
asked about the email mccann
referred the media to her testimony
during the coroner's inquiry blade
defended herself saying that when she
read the email she trusted the local
health authority was doing its job i
felt that someone was taking care of the
cia
the lawyer representing families who
lost loved ones during the tragedy says
the email further proves the health
authority's responsibility in the
tragedy and along with several members
of the national assembly he says only a
public inquiry can truly shed light into
what happened and hold those responsible
accountable we cannot simply
file a few reports brush this aside and
move on we have to honor their memory
and
make sure that we implement durable
change the regional authority which took
over the private long-term care facility
declined to speak to us the coroner's
report is expected in the next few
months gloria enriquez global news
quebec city